if you want to understand fighting you
have to begin at the beginning
and the beginning
is awareness
awareness is the perception of a
situation
and the situation we are going to talk
about is called conflict
all fighting is conflict but not all
conflict is fighting
there are at least three major contexts
for conflict
the dominant context the competitive
context and the non-dominant context
if we want to talk about fighting the
competitive context is what we're
interested in
if you want to master fighting you'll
want to master the competitive context
this is what fighting is
competition
in the competitive context all parties
have near equal skill and assets
when one party attempts to overcome the
other
this creates struggle
all fighting is a struggle
if there was no struggle there would be
no fight
when two or more parties are in
competition they are pitting their
assets and their skills against one
another
assets are the things you rely upon to
make something happen
assets come in many flavors including
internal and external
all of these asset types can be summed
up by the four major assets
these major assets include power speed
attrition and span
let's look at each of these assets
individually
power is the amount of work that can be
done in a single action
speed is the number of actions that can
be made in a given interval
attrition is the amount of work that can
be managed in a given interval
and span is the interval that must be
overcome in order to do work
these four major assets tell us what we
have to work with
and
against in competition
these are the tools we'll use in order
to overcome our adversaries and the
tools that they will use in order to
overcome us
the act of applying these assets is
called skill
if you want to master fighting the first
thing you probably think about is skill
skill is what enables you to apply your
assets
in a fight skill is punching kicking
throwing submissions and holds
with great skill it may be possible for
you to overcome someone with even
greater assets than you have
however this is a slippery slope
in order to better understand the
relationship of skills to assets let's
compare them to something you might have
a little more familiarity with
let's compare them to money and your
ability to manage it
you probably know that the ability to
manage money is very important
a person who is good at managing money
can stretch a dollar a long way or even
turn one dollar into two
but the skill is always limited by how
much money you have
the money you have is like your assets
if you have enough money managing it
becomes much less important because even
if you have poor management skills you
could probably buy everything you want
while skill is very important it's
always limited by how many assets you
have
even the best money manager in the world
can't buy more things than elon musk
simply because elon has more money
while skill is very important it's
always limited by assets
when you're in a competitive environment
this fact governs everything
so if you want to master fighting you
should understand that what you are
using to compete with is both your
skills and assets
and skill is much less dominant than
assets
looking back at our earlier analogy we
could see why assets are so much more
important than skill
for example if you had a ton of money
but no skill you can still get all the
things you want
but if you had a ton of skill and no
money
you couldn't go anywhere with the skill
[Music]
this is why a seasoned brazilian jiu
jitsu black belt could lose a grappling
match to someone with no skill at all
who happen to be one of the strongest
men in the world
the assets that are brought to the
grappling match by the strongman
are much greater than the skill brought
by the grappler
so is this all there is to fighting
simply matching up skills and assets and
whoever has the greatest combination
wins
no
there's much much more to fighting than
this
to learn more check out the next episode